[Musique]
euh monsieur Gordon Moore qui était
professeur à mit dans les années
60 a découvert que depuis entre 62 et 65
les performances des composants
électroniques avaient augmenté fortement
et du coup il a extrapolé ça en disant
que c'était une loi et que ça allait
toujours être vrai et donc euh disons
que l'énoncé simple consiste à dire les
performances des composants électronique
augmente exponentiellement avec une
constante de temps de l'ordre de 2 ans
c'est-à-dire que ils sont multipliés par
3 en 2 ans ça que ça veut
dire ceci énoncé en 1965 est toujours
vrai et ça c'est tout à fait
extraordinaire et si c'est vrai c'est
que quand les industriels qui fabriquent
des composants se sont aperç de son de
l'existence de la loi de mour vers
199095 ils ont pris la loi de mour comme
critère pour leurs investissements et
donc à ce moment-là loademour au lieu de
au lieu d'être un constat est devenu le
support le support du progrès et et nous
en sommes toujours là nous sommes en
2012 et bien c'est encore vrai mais
comme vous l'avez
rappelé nous ne sommes pas capables de
comprendre ce que c'est qu'une constante
de temps de 2 ans constante de temps de
2 ans c'est fantastiquement rapide ça
n'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire du
monde que la technologie avance avec
telle vitesse et nous ne nous avons une
faculté
d'assimilation qui est qui a une
constante de temps de l'ordre d'une
génération une génération il faut une
génération pour assimiler vraiment une
grande avancée technique et alors cette
génération c'est 30 ans entre entre les
parents et les enfants donc différence
de entre 2 ans et 30 ans et le résultat
c'est que toutes la structur social
mondial sont
[Musique]
bouleversé il faut se demander qu'est-ce
qu'on doit faire aujourd'hui nous nous
avons un monde qui tend vers la
connexion universelle c'està-dire que
tout le monde est connecté avec tout le
monde et ça c'est véritablement
mystérieux on sait pas vraiment comment
comment s'y prendre pour gérer ça à
l'heure actuelle
les populations très pauvr et
populations
riches sont ce qui sont qui restent
toujours extrêmement lointaines tendent
à se rapprocher par la collection alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est ça
c'est ça ça le mystère le mystère de
notre
temps je je classe des populations en
fonction de leur
revenus les populations développées
ont 100 € par jour par personne les
populations pauvres on en un 1 € par
jour par personne je revient d'un voyage
une mission à Haïti un pays de 100
millions d'habitants 60 % des gens ont
un dollar par jour nous habitons en
France dans un pays où la
moyenne c'est de l'ordre de 80 moyen ça
veut dire qu' il y a quelques gens
pauvres disons 5 % de la population qui
est pauvre mais en moyenne en moyenne
nous sommes 100 fois au-dessus du niveau
de Haïti et pourtant les gens de Haïti
nous parlent du moins ils reçoivent
notre message ils reçoivent notre
message de de
consommation comment parce que tout le
monde regarde la télévision et dans la
télévision qu'est-ce qu'on voit et bien
on voit des des gens dans des superb
voitures avec beaucoup de publicité j'ai
regardéis la télévision là-bas beaucoup
de publicité avec des produits de gens
riches et voilà les gens pauvres les
gens qui n'ont rien qui n même pas de
maison parce qu'elle a été détruite par
le trument terire et qui pourtant vivent
virtuellement dans le monde des riches
al c'est la connexion qui est
véritablement le fait
nouveau alors quand vous parlez
d'éthique et ben on sait pas quoi faire
véritablement et euh je ne pense pas je
ne pense pas que on puisse continuer
c'est ça le sujet de mon livre du siècle
des menaces on peut pas continuer comme
ça ça ne va pas continuer comme ça vous
avez un light motif de l'ensemble des
classes politiques
mondiales qui
est le la méthode euh pour par exemple
sortir de la crise c'est la croissance
alors c'est c'est c'est le Light motif
la
croissance alors à l'heure actuelle nous
avons une croissance importante c'est
les G dit émergents de l'ordre de 5 6 %
même 10 % par an en Chine mais 5 6 % un
peu partout et puis une croissance
beaucoup plus faible dans les pays
développés parce qu'il sature n'importe
comment on peut plus avec la loi de
disons de rement maxima bien connu de
tous les économistes et bien on voit que
le il peut pas y avoir de croissance
supérieure à 1 ou 2 % dans les pays
développés quoi quoi que raconent nos
dirigeants de quelque partie qu'il soit
mais c'est cette croissance même S n'est
que 1 ou 2 % par an ou et bien elle
s'adresse à un monde fini un monde où il
y a des ressources qui sont bien bien
bien limitées et donc quand vous avez à
l'intérieur d'un récipient fermé vous
avez
disons un crocodile qui grandit qui veut
manger de plus en plus et alors que il y
a un nombre fini de de canard à
l'intérieur du pot ben forcément une
fois que tous les canards ont été a été
mangés va arriver quelque chose au
crocodile ça c'est sûr tout ça ça a été
mis en équation magnifiquement dans un
livre célèbre de vit Voltera paru 1910
quelque chose comme ça ça peut être les
leçons sur la lutte pour la vie ù lui il
raisonnait sur des sols et des requins
dans une mer fermée alors vous avez des
requins qui mangent les sols ben euh
quand il y a plus de sol le nombre de
requin diminue et puis après ça puisque
le requin diminue le nombre de sol
augmente et puis et donc les deux
systèmes aussi là entre et donc vous
avez des équations intégrales très très
dit d'équation de terrain qui qui euh
très bien décrivent décrivent le
problème mais si vous êtes dans un dans
un un monde
fini vous avez mangé t les T les sols a
plus requinors nous nous sommes dans
dans ce système
[Musique]
oui c'estd que moi je ne veux pas
prédire un jour et je suis pas pour
l'apocalypse pour pour la
catastrophe je dis simplement voilà la
situation elle est très simple vous avez
une quantité finie de source et c'est et
et cette cette quantité finie elle sera
à un moment ou un autre consommée bon à
ce ce moment on sait pas où il est et
donc
là il y a beaucoup de controversse des
gens qui disent mais non pas du tout ça
va s'arranger alors on dit l'homme s'en
est toujours tiré voilà ça c'est le
raisonnement classique on on a toujours
trouvé des solutions on va s'en tirer
donc les gens
qui parlent despuis se trompe la la
controverse c'est là mais je crois que
c'est pas vrai à plusieurs titres
premièrement
le nous ne sommes nous sommes dans une
situation jamais vue on peut pas dire
l'homme s'en est toujours tiré
aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai la loi de
mour c'est quelque chose de nouveau
constant de 2 ans c'est quelque chose de
nouveau parce que cette ce pr ce
progrress technique qui correspond à une
consommation accrue et donc et c'est et
cette consommation elle va avec la
croissance de mettons au minimum 2 % 2 %
par an c'est énorme s'il y avait une
constante de temps de 100 ans ça serait
pas grave mais une constant de temps de
2 ans alors là c'est là c'est là où est
le problème alors la seconde erreur de
ce raisonnement pour moi est encore plus
grave la science et la technique vont
nous fournir des solutions alors j'ai
donné un très bel exemple qui vient
d'arriver on parlait d'épuisement de
pétrole appel le P oil et ben non c'est
pas vrai parce qu' a une grande
découverte technique qui vient d'être
faite c'est l'hydrofracking et
l'hydrofracking qui permet de multiplier
euh les réserves et donc on manquera pas
de pétrole alors là
euh je pense que il y a euh peut-être
deux erreurs dans ce genre de
raisonnement euh la première c'est que
même
l'hydrofraaking fournit des ressources
nouvelles mais pas
beaucoup même si on on trouve un un très
grand très riche bassin de pétrole et
bien il va correspondre
à 10 jours de consommation mondiale euh
une une consommation la consommation
mondiale est de mettons 90 millions de
barils par jour si on trouve un gisement
de 10 milliards on trouve ça
extraordinaire ext c'est ça n'arrive pas
le jugement qu'on VI trouver en guyan là
qui dont on parle beaucoup entre 1 et 5
bon et alors qu'est-ce ça veut dire euh
80 millions de barils par jour ça fait 3
milliard par an et donc si vous avez un
énorme gisement énorme gisement de 5
milliards ça fait 2 mois 1 6e d'année
bon alors trouvons en 10 ça fait ça fait
pas mal 10 bon et bien 10 ça fait donc
euh 5
ans et donc et donc le la grandeur du
problème est
sous-estimée quand on parle de
ressources nouvelles B ça c'est c'est
c'est la première erreur mais une erreur
bien plus fondamentale c'est ce que
c'est que résume en une phrase plus de
productivisme ou de consumérisme ne peut
pas guérir les mots du
consumérisme et je
donne quelques exemples par exemple avec
avec les automobiles vous avez
une très grand progrès dans les 30
dernières années qui a été fait dans la
consommation des moteurs à qu temps et
on peut dire que maintenant euh on
a au lieu de
8 L d'essence par 100 km on en consomme
5 en moyenne c'est énorme avec des gros
investissements on peut vraiment dire
grand succès
et bien la consommation d'essence n'a
pas baissé elle a augmenté et pour une
raison très simple c'est que à partir du
moment vous avez une voiture qui
consomme moins elle est moins chè donc
elle devient accessible à des gens plus
pauvres et donc ces gens plus sont très
nombreux a plus de voitures qui
fonctionnent vous avez deux fois plus de
voiture que vousaviez quand les moteurs
fonctionnent mal donc le prog technique
à engendré non pas une économie mais au
contraire une augmentation une
augmentation des
consommations alors donc ça je donne ça
comme exemple pour donner bien d'autres
exemples il faut il faut bien comprendre
que ça ça ça ne marchera pas si vous si
vous trouvez un système d'hydrofracking
et bien ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que l'essence aux États-Unis devient
moins cher et c'est ce qu'on constate le
prix à la pompe est en train de baisser
aux États-Unis à cause de
l'hydrofracking et bien il y aura plus
de gens qui utiliseront plus de voitures
et le résultat sera une consommation
plus importante et l'hydrofraaking
finalement bien il aura apporté
maisettons 10 an 1500 de répis mais à
l'échelle où je me place c'estàdire 2050
entre 2050 et
2100 et bien ça ne se fait que aggraver
la
situation
[Musique]
oui ça ceci conduit à des considérations
bien compliquées mais dans lesquel je
vais entrer tout de même effectivement
c'est n nous voyons que les découvertes
de pétrole sont devenus depuis 1980 90
inférieur à à la consommation donc on
quand on dit que les réserves restent
constantes c'est pas vrai ell reste
elle diminue et donc on va être obligé
d'utiliser du pétrole dans des lieux
plus coûteux à forêt et à
exploiter et donc ça veut dire que la
conséquence certaine je ne sais je ne
parle pas de pénurie de pétrole c'est
possible qu' est mais la conséquence
certaine c'est l'augmentation du prix
donc ça c'est sûr comme vous le dites
très justement le le prix du pétrole va
augmenter et maintenant je voudrais
entrer dans une disons discussion très
simple de quelques conséquences et
surtout dans les conséquences agricoles
faire 1960 on croyait tous qu'il va y
avoir il avait y avoir une pénuerie une
pénuerie de d'aliments de nourriture
dans le monde et ça n'est pas arrivé ça
n'est pas arrivé parce qu'il y a eu
quelque chose que les Indiens ont ont
inventé s'appelait la révolution verte
la révolution verte elle consiste
à augmenter l'irrigation et surtout
augmenter l'emploi des engrais emploi
des engrais c'est ce qu'on appelle NPK
azote phosphore
potassium et
effectivement cette politique a empêché
toute famine on peut dire en première
approximation toute famine depuis 1960
il n'y a pas eu de famine de temps en
temps bon il y a des coins du monde qui
n'ont pas assz il y a un milliard de
gens qui n'ont pas assez à manger on le
sait mais il y a pas de famille
universelle
en particulier dans des grands pays
peuplés comme l'Inde ou la
Chine regardons ce que c'est que NPK he
le
l'azote 1 kg d'azote en gris é=al 1 kg
de
pétrole oui il faut il faut 1 kg il faut
1 kg d'azote 1 kg de pétrole pour 1 kil
d'azote alors quand vous avez dit ça
vous voyez l'impact
l'impact extrêmement sérieux de
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole et
d'ailleurs quand il y a une augmentation
du prix du pétrole en 2008 vous avez une
famine car les paysans pourrait plus
acheter de
d'engrais et ça c'est le genre de
considération qui échappe au public
complètement pourtant c'est pas
compliqué alors en d'ailleurs on peut
faire le même genre le même genre de de
remarque en ce qui sont concerne
euh les autres composants comme euh le
potassium
potassium mines de potasse sont en voie
d'épuisements il y en a des très grandes
mines de potasse mais là encore comme le
pétrole le prix va augmenter alors non
seulement le
prix engrais auté va augmenter mais le
prix aussi des
engrais potassique augmenter et enfin en
ce qui concerne le phosphate et bien il
y a des mines qui sont
surexploitation à partir de 203
la production mondiale de pétrole va se
mettre à baisser et elle va tomber à 1
ti3 au maximum à la fin du siècle donc
ça veut dire que les trois ingrédients
principaux de la révolution verte vont
voir augmenter leur prix et ça ça veut
dire que les paysans qui vont souffrir
et souffrir parce qu'ils vont voir le
prix des engrais augmenter tellement
qu'ils pouront plus
acheter ça c'est pour moi une pénurie
typique qui est passé sous silence
complètement on dit mais non on on saura
on saura nourrir la
population en fait les gens qui disent
qu'on saura nourrir la
population ajoute à condition qu'on ne
mange plus de viande à condition qu'on
mange plus de viande parce que la viande
et surtout la viande de bœuf est
extrêmement coûteuse en eau et en
ressources en général il faut je sais
pas 1000 fois plus de d'eau
pour 1 kg de bœuf que 1 kg de blé et
donc euh on peut on ne pourra pas avec
la croissance actuelle de la
consommation en viande surtout en Chine
et bien on ne va pas pouvoir supporter
euh la l'agriculture mais vous voyez
pour résumer tout ça il y a quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup frappé il y a 3
ans j'ai été invité par l'Académie des
Sciences de Chine euh à passer un
certain temps à Beijing
pour évaluer un grand laboratoire
spatial chinois donc je sais pas si je
me suis immergé dans la dans la vie
quotidienne des chercheurs chinois
pendant un certain
temps un peu plus d'un mois et PU pour
faire ce rapport passionnant d'ailleurs
et euh donc j'ai fini par je crois avoir
compris quel est le grand objectif à
long terme de la Chine tel qu'il a été
défini par l'Académie des sciences dans
des des de Chine dans des documents
bien
pensé l'objectif de la Chine c'est de
devenir un pays en 2050 un pays
moyennement développé moyennement
développé ça veut dire quoi moyennement
développé alors j'ai essayer de
comprendre en me disant il faut traduire
ça de façon quantitative alors il y a
les gens à un dollar par jour les gens à
100 dollars par jour très bien mais
supposons que l'objectif la Chine soit
moyennement la la moyenne 40 prenons 40
dollars par jour et les Chinois
aujourd'hui ils sont très combien ils
sont à 6 donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
multiplier entre 6 et 8 la consommation
des Chinois aujourd'hui pour obtenir la
consommation des Chinois en 2050
et oui alors là il faut bien réfléchir
on peut naturellement imaginer que les
Indiens ont le même objectif alors ça
veut dire qu'il y a trois de mettons de
l'ordre de grandeur de 3 milliards de
gens dont la consommation va être
multipliée par 6 alors c'est pas
soutenable alors nous sommes à 7
milliards c'est pas soutenable à 7
milliards tout le monde est d'accord
pour estimer qu'en 2050 on passe à 9 ce
n'est pas sout mais c'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas 9 milliards il faut il faut
prendre les 3 milliards des neuf qui
sont chinois et indiens et faut
multiplier par 5 ou quelque chose comme
ça et donc ça fait 15 15 en plus
grossièrement un calcul un calcul simple
vous montre queà ce moment-là vous
tombez entre 20 et 20 et 25 milliards de
gens donc ça veut dire que grossièrement
très très schématiquement la
consommation mondiale sera multiplié par
3 de l'ordre de 20 25 par rapport à ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les
pénuries seront aggravées par la science
et la technologie au contraire de ce
qu'on pense donc nous sommes en présence
d'un problème disons où les ressources
sont consommées à une trop grande
vitesse et que les méthodes qui ont
permis d'augmenter cette consommation
science et technologie ne feront que
l'augmenter donc ce n'est pas de ce
côté-là qu'il faut chercher pour trouver
une solution à nos problèmes futurs
une seconde possibilité ça serait de de
faire appel à une gouvernance politique
par exemple a un super ONU qui
déciderait que personne dans le monde ne
peut consommer plus que 1 L d'essence
par jour quelque chose dans ce Gou là ou
1 kil de pain par an par jour donc un
gouvernement mondial qui édicterait des
règles qui empêcheraient la
surconsommation tout le monde sait que
ça marche pas ça ce n'est pas une
solution nous nous l'avons vu l'année
dernière avec la conférence de
Copenhague mais nous le voyons tous les
jours tous les jours et pour bien faire
comprendre la fausseté de cette piste il
faut il suffit de citer le président
Bush le père
la le niveau de vie des États-Unis n'est
pas négociable niveau de vie des
États-Unis n'est pas négociable et ceci
c'est vrai pour tous les gouvernements
si Vous adressez au président de la
République française il dira le niveau
de vie des français n'est pas négociable
il il faut qu'il augmente mais il ne
peut pas diminuer et donc tous les
gouvernements dès qu'on touche à
l'approvisonnement en ressources vitales
essentiell est le même c'est-à-dire n'y
touchez
pas donc ça veut dire que il n'est pas
possible de réduire le niveau de vie il
est pas possible de réduire les
consommations par la politique et je je
suis prêt à discuter avec n'importe qui
sur ce sujet et à gagner n'importe quel
Paris ce n'est pas possible et quand les
gens les gens l'année dernière ont été
surpris par l'échec de la conférence de
Copenhague et bien ça prouve qu'ils ont
pas réfléchi du tout parce qu'est-ce qui
est arrivé il y a des rigolos comme les
Européens qui sont venus pour dire ah
faut faire bien attention au climat et
puis il y a des gens sérieux comme les
américains les Chinois les Russes qui
sont venus et qui ont dit pour nous
raconte des histoires il y a pas de
changement climatique alors que leurs
scientifiques disent qu'il y en a un
mais les politique ont dit qu'it pas
point la ligne ça s'est arrêté
conférence de s arrêté l'autre
conférence de Ry ça été la même chose
mais naturellement tout ça s'est
déguisé sous des discours donc ni
science et technologie ni politique
qu'est-ce qui reste qu'est-ce voilà
c'est ça c'est comme ça que du moins que
j'ai raisonné et bien moi je je constate
que il y a des habitudes alimentaires
par exemple je prend ça comm exemple qui
sont
codifiés par les religions exemple là
les religions hindouistes interdisent la
consommation de VI
il y a pas de consommation de viande en
Inde et il y en a pas pour des raisons
appelonsles spirituelles ou religieuses
ri mais ça existait aussi de au
Moyen-Âge on avait le carême pendant un
mois pouvait pas manger de viande et
d'ailleurs pour l'Église catholique le
vendredi on mange pas de viande et les
gens acceptaient ça très volontiers
pourquoi parce que le petit Jésus
l'avait dit donc il y a la un gisement
de d'action
possible essayer d'utiliser
des motivations religieuses pour
modifier les murs et je pense qu'il a il
y a même pas de paradoxe làdedans c'est
vraiment c'est c'est vrai c'est c'est
comme ça on peut modifier les murs par
des considérations religieuses et donc
il faut s'adresser aux gens qui
commandent
les
disons qui commande les religions et
pour ça il faut s'adresser à des
religions qui sont structurées où il y a
un chef il y en a qu'une seule au fond
l'Église catholique l'Église catholique
elle a quoi elle elle a un chef elle a
des troupes elle a une structure une
hiérarchie une habitude euh
de de disons de l'obéissance
l'obéissance un mot un mot très
catholique et donc pourquoi ne pas
s'adresser à l'église catholique qui a
un milliard de fidèles et si elle était
convaincue et bien elle convaincra les
autres par des
négociations par exemple on me dit que
l'Église orthodoxe est sensible à
l'heure actuelle à ce genre de
considération quel que soit ce qu'on
pense de l'Église orthodoxe bien
pourquoi ne pas la mobiliser aussi et
donc ce raisonnement m'a conduit à
m'adresser à l'église catholique en lui
en demandant est-ce que vous pouvez pas
vous convaincre vous convaincre que nous
sommes dans une situation périlleuse et
que vous pouvez y faire quelque
[Musique]
chose pas du tout je suis pas résigné
scientifiquement puisque je je crois
comme je l'ai expliqué que le disons
l'action de la science et la technologie
va dans un certain sens et ce sens il a
pendant presque toute ma vie je l'ai
admiré j'étais d'accord je trouvais que
c'était extrêmement bien que et c'est
pour ça que j'étais scientifique en
partie pour ça que j'étais scientifique
c'est que il y avait des retomberé sur
l'ensemble de l'humanité ça augmenté son
niveau de vie et donc et c'est c'est
vrai mais ce qui est arrivé c'est que la
machine s'est emballé et et maintenant
elle s'est emballé à cause de ses
moteurs
internes le le le point principal est
très difficile disons il y a deux il y a
deux tendances il y a d'une part la
tendance démographique augment des gens
puis d'autre part une autre tendance qui
est l'augmentation des besoins de chacun
qui que chacun veut avoir plus chacun
veut plus bon mais c'est personneavait
pensé quand quand j'avais 2reâge
personne ne pensait que la machine
allait s'emballer personne personne ne
pensait que la population du monde
allait doubler en 30
ans quelque chose de monstrueux passer 3
à 7 milliards brusquement comme ça en
quelques dizaines
d'années
[Musique]
tout à fait vous avez fait raison mais
ça pourtant ça va continuer alors bon on
je veux bien admettre qu'il y a une
saturation dans la croissance
démographique mais enfin le chiffre de 9
milliards est absolument certain
peut-être 9,5 et chens que et 10 à la
fin du siècle hein on dit que ça va
diminu après c'est pas vrai ça va ça ça
ne sature pas en 2050 ça continue à
augmenter beaucoup plus lentement enfin
malgré tout j'ai expliqué tout que que
c'est ces 9 ou 10 milliards ne sont pas
le problème parce que en même temps les
besoins disons augmentent parce que les
gens veulent plus et donc c'est pas 9
milliards auquels il faut penser mais
20 ça c'est quelque chose que on disons
on navait pas du tout imaginé et que
vous nimaginez pas vous non plus les
gens de votre âge ne pensent pas qu'il
va y avoir à nourrir trois fois plus de
personnes qu'il y en a M et que donc la
consommation en eau et cetera va
augmenter vous avez un pays comme le
Yémen ça ça j'aime bien parler du Yémen
il y a 25 millions d'habitants 22
millions d'habitants au yen maintenant
en 2050 sonont 50 population aura doublé
alors la question à poser quel est le
niveau de la nappe fréatique c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est pas il y a pas
d'autres questions à poser alors cette
nappe elle était à 10 m il y a 30 ans
aujourd'hui 1 km pour fort maintenant à
à alors on fort avec des pompes
subventionnées au desessens des pompes
subventionnées on descend à 1000 m bon
alors c'est fini à000 m il a plus rien
du tout donc ça veut dire cette
population 45 million d'habitants elle 0
l d'eau par jour alors qu'est-ce qu'elle
va
faire bon mais vous n'y pensez pas c'est
pas le genre de problème que vous vous
posez quand on pass sur Moyen-Orient on
parle des cailloux de Jérusalem devrait
seattacher aucune importance ce qui est
important c'est la NA fratique la
fratique de de Palestine qui tend vers
zéro ceci moi je vais en Inde j'ai
beaucoup travaillé en Inde je vois des
villes comme Madras qu'elle s'appelle
maintenant
shenille quand je commençais à aller en
Inde il y a il y a 40 ans et 500000
habitants aujourd'hui a 5 millions quand
je vais à chena je demande à mes amis où
est le niveau de Lafti cque je vais à
côté à ade exactement la même situation
maintenant 5 millions d'habitants votre
na fratique cque il y en a plus alors
comment on fait vous avez des dizaines
de millions d'habitants il y a plus
d'eau à ce moment-là vous avez conflit
alors moi j'ai j'ai écrit dans le siècle
des menaces que on est ch prê pas aux
armes de destruction massive alors il y
en a deux de catégorie il y en a une
àquelle tout le monde pense qui arrivera
peut-être pas et il y en a une autre
àquelle personne ne pense et qui va
arriver sans doute celle à qui tout le
monde pense c'est le
nucléaire donc vous avez vu arriver sur
la scène mondiale
l'Iran l'atome iranien bon ben si ça
avait pas été en Iran ça aurait été
encore et du Nord ou au Pakistan et
cetera l'endroit n'importe peu ce qui
est intéressant c'est la cause c'est la
façon dont ça se produit c'est que les
frustrations qui sont créées par le
contraste entre les pays pauves et les
pays riches devenus conscient de la part
des pays pauvres c'est ça ça le fait
nouveau prise de conscience des pays
pauvres qu'ils sont frustrés qu'ils sont
dominés qu'ils sont moqués cette
tendance vers le Spirit appelons la
spiritualisme est-ce que l'on peut la
canaliser pour en faire quelque chose
d'utilisable moi c'est ce que j'ai pensé
qu'on pouit faire avec l'Église
catholique je pense que je me suis
trompé que l'Église catholique elle me
elleelle m'en verra me Rabiller
hein et que j'en serai pour le ridicule
bon mais en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne par exemple les pays islamiques
et bien on se dirige semble se diriger
vers vers les vers les les armes de
destruction massive bon mais alors donc
la seconde catégorie d'armes àion
massive c'est le biologique alors tout
le monde sait que c'est une arme qui qui
a éé un tout petit peu employé une fois
et mais elle a un potentiel formidable
formidable ça veut dire vous savez en
latin form ça veut dire peur donc
formidable ça veut dire terrifiant ça
veut pas dire épatant ça veut dire qui
fait peur et le potentiel des armes
biologiques est est formidable mais je
veux pas en parler plus parce que c'est
un sujet en
[Musique]
soi alors il y il y a on a un que que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle le chiffre
et le songe qui a été publié en 8 13 et
qui est sur l'histoire des sciences et
euh je veux pas il est rempli d'un
certain nombre de d'analyses nouvelles
et paradoxales et il a plu j'aimerais
qu'il continue à plaire il a hérédité
d'ailleurs mais euh les livres
auquel euh vous voulez que je je fasse
allusion euh il y en a deux le premier
euh c'est un
livre écrit avec le Père Jacques Arnou
dominicain et c'est venu du du fait que
le père Arnou n'a pas aimé le livre
précédent que j'avais écrit l'histoire
des siècles du siè l'introduction au
siècle des menaces et il m'a dit vous ma
conclusion
c'était il y a rien à faire l'humanité
va dans le mur et on n'y peut rien alors
il m' a dit vous n'avez pas le droit
d'écrire ça et donc que on va en
disputer on a décidé on va faire une
dispute au sens euh médiéval du terme
puisque puis que lui était Dominique
pourquoi pas
euh dans ce livre nous avons analysé
l'évolution telle que euh je l'ai décrit
dans les entretiens que nous venons
d'avoir et euh nous on en concluait euh
que peut-être peut-être on pouvait
s'adresser à l'église catholique et
c'est c'est ça le c'est ça le livre il
se termine en fait par une série
d'exposés sur un sujet qui auquel je
tiens beaucoup qui est la méchanceté
humaine et je donne trois exemples de
méchanceté humaine qui sont dures à lire
très très dur à lire le premier c'est ce
que les Allemands appel les Z commando
euh des camps
d'extermination le le second c'est la
révolution culturelle de
medung
avec certaines insistance sur les élèves
qui ont mangé leur leur professeurs
élèves
cannibales Paris que ça se continue
d'ailleurs et puis la
troisième c'est la façon don nous
traitons les animaux et ça c'est
vraiment un sujet qui me tient beaucoup
à cœur et qui est occulté totalement
absolument par tout le monde par les
lecteur du livre qui qui recule devant
le dernier les 10 dernières pages où
j'explique avec les chiffres et des
renseignements qui sont donnés euh
officiellement la façon dont on traite
des milliards des milliards d'animaux
depuis les poules jusqu'au cochon en
passant par les vaches des conditions
abominables et et qui nous
permettent de savourer notre
œuf à la coque le matin et si on y
pensait vraiment sur la façon dont ces
œufs à la coque ont été
obtenus et bien on pourrait pas le
manger je peux vous dire que c'est un
sujet qui est totalement si occulté que
personne n'a relevé qu'il y avait une
quinzaine de pages sur ce sujet avec
chiffr à la pluie dans mon dans notre
livre ça ça m'a frappé tout de même et
d'ailleurs quelques personnes qui ont eu
le courage de lire mon livre mont dit
qu'ils arrivaient pas à lire la fin et
pourtant et
pourtant tout ce qui est là-dedans est
tout à
fait tout à fait
officiel dans mon dernier livre qui
s'appelle l'action sœur du rêve pourquoi
ce titre alors c'est une citation de
brler
oui je sortirai de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas la sœur du rêve voilà le d'où
vient le titre et moi je pense le
contraire je pense du moins dans ma vie
et je pense que beaucoup de mes actions
sont sorties je ne dirais pas de rêve
j'aime pas beaucoup le mot rêve enfin
disons
de préoccupation non
rationnelle évidemment le l'exemple le
plus le plus net c'est celui euh qui a
entraîné une grande partie de ma vie
scientifique le rêve le vrai rêve que
j'ai eu en
1967 sur l'exploration de Vénus
l'exploration de Vénus par ballon et qui
fait l'objet de mon premier premier
bouquin Vénus dévoilé j'ai j'ai j'ai eu
un rêve que où j'imaginais que
j'imaginais pas je voyais je voyais un
point lumineux au bord d'un cercle
brillant et ce ce point lumineux aussi
là ça son intensité aussi je me suis
réveillé et j'ai pensé je peux pas vous
dire pourquoi un ballon l'atmosphère de
Vénus et deux cercles un avec
quiosile ça se traduit dans mon esprit
par un ballon àphè de Vénus voilà
l'exemple type du rêve pour moi et et et
j'ai réussi j'ai réussi à placer deux
ballons en l'atmosphère de
Vénus ça m'a pris 18 ans finalement
c'est peu vous êtesace pardon vous êtes
tonace ah oui ah oui je suis très est
ououi
mais c'est pour ça que maintenant je
veux plus faire de recherge spatiale
parce que je sais que tout projet prend
18 ans au moins tous mais alors
donc dans l'action sort du rêve c'est
que effectivement un certain nombre de
choses que j'ai faites sont venu de
disons de vléité de considération plus
ou moins plus ou moins non rationnelle
euh par exemple l'éducation par
satellite qui m'occupe beaucoup à
l'heure actuelle par exemple Haïti c'est
c'est un
rêve un rêve d'un de mes amis indiens
qui étaitomme tout à fait remarquable
qui a créé l'espace indien il est mort
depuis longtemps et qui avait cette idée
qui qui est devenue elle une réalité et
donc il me semble que le problème
naturellement c'est que beaucoup de gens
des rêves qui sont idiots quand je dis
idiot ça veut dire qu'ils vont aboutir à
rien et la plupart des miens sont idiots
la plupart ont aboutit à pas grand-chose
mais il faut tout de même il me semble
choisir parmi ces rêves ceux qui ont
tout de même le plus la plus forte
composante de réalité et donc je crois
que la vie pour réussir sa vie il faut
choisir parmi ses rêvres ceux qui ont
des capacités d'
potentiel d'amener quelque chose qui
soir
faut passer du rêve à la réalité c'est
ça c'est ça la
[Musique]
vie